Paris Hilton oh she's not making it down
the aisle nope
what you're seeing behind me is her and
her former fiance Chris silca we know
they've broken up well Paris thought he
was the love of her life she is now
opening up to the ladies of the talk
about her split for the first time take
a listen
I am doing really good I'm just really
having my me time and I just feel that
when I fall in love I fall in love fast
and hard and it was this whirlwind
romance and I have always been obsessed
with Disney stories and love stories and
I thought it was gonna be my happy
ending and I just realized after time
that it wasn't the right decision
but I wish him the best and you know one
day I would love to get married and have
children but for right now I'm just
focusing on myself and my work
mm Paris well you know what sometimes
the Disney love story doesn't work out
but the couple was together for nearly
two years and when I talked to them
actually before they got engaged I spoke
with them in 2017 on the red carpet at a
gala Paris always attends and supports
the race to erase MS gala in Los Angeles
she brought Chris to this event her and
her family always go to and back then
she was convinced he was the one here's
what she had to say there's really not
anything I would change about either one
of us and in the relationship were
honest and
and it's just finding your best friend
and your soulmate
literally the man of my dreams ever
since I met him seven years ago I had
the biggest crush it's just I feel like
the luckiest girl in the world I'm so
happy
all right well Paris and Chris were
happy then but she's saying now she's
moving forward focusing on herself and
wishing him the best
[Music]
[Applause]